coffee atlanta's finest
just for you buddy respect how's atlanta
been treating you down here i like
atlanta
yeah yeah it's a gold mine down here
what do you say that for
uh it's cheap property you get a lot for
it and there's industry here
i don't think we'll be like that much
longer but maybe for like the next
few years it's just random like
you're not supposed to have opportunity
and
cheap property um right okay like
property value should go up with
opportunity
go los angeles [ __ ] is expensive go to
new york which is expensive i mean i
just bought a place in new york
one bedroom that i'm turning it into one
bedroom it's an alcove
studio with an alcove six hundred
thousand dollars
[Music]
i get a castle out here for six hundred
thousand dollars
right wow yeah so it's like
yeah you have music you have the music
industry out here you have film
is is rapidly growing out here you see
all these shows being filmed we have uh
walking dead is out here like major
shows
yeah and then it's a good comedy scene
too
yeah you got definitely a lot of you
know strong comics
all i'm saying is property should be
more expensive than it is
yeah how long for the opportunity you
get how long you've been performing in
atlanta like what's kind of your
connection here i only came uh
two other times oh okay yeah the recent
yeah one at the atlanta comedy theater
and then i did a little one-nighter
there
and then um and then now i'm doing this
weekend right here
at the punchline comedy diner well that
was that the one last night right
and there was a i mean that was a good
crowd and it seemed most of them
well first they gave you a standing
ovation that was cool
opening the show with a standing ovation
so
it kind of takes away from the standing
o when i leave right because it's like
it's like you gotta stand or else it was
lowered your expectation like i didn't
meet expectations
if you're willing to stand for me to go
on to the stage yeah the least you could
do
is stand when i leave right have people
been doing that a lot lately
um it's weird i have been starting to
get some standing
ovations and it will be like it won't be
like the whole place
i feel like you kind of milk it for the
whole place i just get off before that
because i'm too uncomfortable
but like you know like 15 people will
stand up and then
if you are one of those guys you could
be like oh thank you and you just stand
and then out of sheer awkwardness i
think other people will start to stand
i just get off before then um
but yeah it's happening but it's a
function
i think it's a function of like having
fans show up to your shows
i think it's very difficult to get a
standing ovation from people that do not
know you
even though they find you oftentimes
funnier
right because their expectation might be
lower
your fans support your funny the most
right they'll give it up etc but they're
not going to be
as surprised by your funny as a complete
stranger like some random guy who's 45
years old in the audience that just came
out he's like yeah this guy might be
funny
his expectation is low mm-hmm yeah
a lot of those guys it seemed were from
the podcast they were yelling out
podcast
quotes and everything yeah dick talk
yeah a lot of dick talk ellers yeah no
it's the best dude having a podcast is
the best
it's also great because it it you get
past one of the most frustrating parts
of stand-up
which is and one of my least favorite
parts of stand-up which is
uh introducing an audience to your
sensibility without
alienating them so if these people
already
understand my comedic sensibility where
i'm gonna like you know justify some
horrible [ __ ] and i'm gonna challenge
conventional wisdom
like they're already waiting for that
right right yeah you know when you're a
famous comedian like louis c.k these
type of people like
the audience is ready for these types of
jokes from you right they're not shocked
by it
so when you have some people that are
aware of that
it makes it easier for you to get into
these taboo topics
because you don't need a [ __ ] foot
around it and like risk alienating these
people
yeah i'd imagine with your style you've
probably have gotten some mixed
reactions developing that style oh my
god
yeah girls would go they used to throw
[ __ ] candles at me and [ __ ] like that
like lit candles oh wow people used to
fight i got punched in the face once on
stage
have you ever been booed oh [ __ ] yeah of
course what's uh what's your favorite
booze story
i mean booze aren't even close to us
interesting like booze are easy you
could flip a boo
okay you know what i mean like that's
not like when people
boo me it doesn't like if i'm getting
booed
it doesn't count in the same way as a
boo
it's not like boo it's like boo you're
bad you're not funny it's
boo i don't enjoy
you justifying these things that i think
are horrible
i don't mind that because that boo is
just the same as an
o it's just their way of saying i don't
agree with this i need everybody in this
room to know
that i don't agree with that sensibility
a boo of just you're not funny
that's gotta hurt i don't think i've
ever got one of those but that's gotta
hurt that is just
rough i've bombed plenty of times but
never to the point
where it was so offensive never where
the bombing was so
just outright offensive to the audience
that they felt a need
to make sound back at you right
like they would just rather come up and
punch you in the face is that whatever
yeah that was i was just
i was my first time ever doing a hood
room and i was just talking [ __ ] to one
of these guys in a crowd and he just
walked up and punched me in the face
and i threw them out and they handed me
back the microphone they're like all
right man keep doing your thing
did you ever go back yeah next week yeah
that's what you gotta do man you gotta
do it
yeah right away seems like you have a
nice mixed following now
like last night the crowd was a little
bit everybody there yeah that's funny
the funny
that's what club owners always say they
don't know how to say we're surprised
that black people are at your show
so they go uh wow your audience is uh
quite uh diverse
quite diverse a little urban in here
tonight exactly
you know who's not a fan of that the
waitresses
[Laughter]
apparently they're not tipping as much
as the white patrons apparently
that stereotype might have some truth to
it apparently
apparently i can't say allegedly
according to waitresses
at the punchline comedy diner oh they
just told you that
this week that's funny i always ask the
waitresses how they're doing mm-hmm
you know they taking care of you this
that the other yeah and uh they just
gave a couple eye rolls
so you understand that hustle you've
worked in restaurants of course yeah you
got to make your money man
they're not getting paid they make money
on tips but you were you were a manager
right man just yeah a couple of mans two
restaurants into the grounds
put two restaurants out of business very
proud of that were those both in
california no one in california
then then moved back to the city and uh
just put that one right down the drain
too what did you do
i think the restaurants are tough right
there they can be doomed already but
like
i just gave you know
i just gave suggestions that were really
bad too that didn't help
i mean with the second one that wasn't
my fault i walked into a doom situation
and it was i walked into the doom
situation and i
didn't want to
i didn't want to like not say i didn't
want to i wanted to turn around but i
didn't want to put the effort into
turning around because i didn't care
right like i wanted to do stand-up but i
didn't want to manage restaurants you
know it was just a job right after
college and it just opened up and i was
like all right i'll do this i'll be the
gm of a restaurant
but i didn't i wasn't like going how do
we change this how do we fix this what
should we do
right i was okay to babysit which is
what you're doing when you manage
a restaurant you're a [ __ ] babysitter
for adults that don't want to be there
nobody wants to be there nobody wants it
like if any first of all any like
yeah if you work at a restaurant you
have a dream to do something else
so nobody that's there wants to be there
so you have to watch people that don't
want to be there
and tell them what to do that don't want
to be there and they're adults
so you're you couldn't use your
psychology to kind of manipulate them at
all you try
but you know what i mean but at the same
time it's like you try to motivate them
right but like i also have a tough time
motivating people that like don't want
to work
like i can motivate you if you want it
and i can say that you want it i can
make you believe in yourself
like if you want it but you don't
believe in yourself i can make you
believe in yourself and i can make you
believe that you can do something
i can't deal with laziness and like a
lack of integrity
just do a [ __ ] job mm-hmm you know
like because because i just i don't have
any respect for those people so it's
like
it's hard to manage people you don't
have respect for
just do the job well i would like this
podcast to become
one of the most popular in the world can
you convince me
to make that happen sure absolutely well
you're already doing it
yeah yeah i got you i guess you got me
on there no but you're always doing it
every week you have
you're committed to it it's consistent
right yeah every monday well if you want
to be the most popular world then why
why can't it yeah why can't it be i
don't understand why it can't be
what are what are some of your biggest
goals like
because i'm saying most popular podcasts
in the world what are some of the goals
you've said
that they're like high reaching
brilliant idiots to be the most popular
podcast in the world
uh you know and i think we're on the way
to doing that it's just
and then what basically the how i've
attached attacked anything is just
okay who is doing this the best how do i
do it better than them
so you have to look at what you want
and then who has it and then how you can
do it better than them
so it's very simple you know so how can
you make this podcast you're
interviewing people okay who's got the
best interview podcast
you know in this field okay who is he oh
he's interviewing more famous people
than me
all right i gotta interview more famous
people he's interviewing more
interesting people than me you could
turn that off if you want to oh yeah
get rid of those sounds that would be
great no no no no no wait
we're not just a right there yeah
um just analyze who's doing the thing
successfully and then be better than
that
who are some people you've been
analyzing in terms of podcasts
or just in your career all of the stuff
you've been doing i mean
you know for stand-up it was like i just
looked at the game i was like okay what
do i need to do first of all i need to
get undeniably funny
that's the first thing how do i get
unnaturally funny get on stage as much
as i can
so i was barking for a club which means
handing out tickets
to go to a club in exchange for stage
time so i was getting up tons of times a
week in front of real audiences
very early on in my in my career i was
probably getting up
five seven times a week in front of real
audiences early in my career
unheard of so i had to say new york this
is in new york
yeah then i stopped working at one of
those clubs i kind of got like fired
from barking or one club close they
didn't ask me to work at the other one
so i uh
i basically we found this other place
that was around the block
and they had shows there and um they
were just kind of like free shows asking
people to come off the street and i got
involved in that club and i started
working for one of the guys there and i
we were just kind of friendly and i was
running his shows i just found a place
to get up
consistently and i started running a
couple shows there with friends we were
just asked pete strangers from the
streets to come in
and um it was great because when you
have your own show you have your own
show
a lot of times it might be repeat
audience
so you can't work the same jokes out
because it's the same audience
so it's good because you're practicing
new jokes but you're not getting good at
anything
you know it's like you're learning a new
um like pool shot every week
it's like you're not getting really
better pool you're just kind of getting
marginally better
at these new jokes that you never really
get to try but we could work on the same
jokes for months
because it was a different group of
people coming in every week
so we did that then i once i felt like i
was
undeniably funny
at least funny to the point where i feel
like i could you know be on stage with
these other guys who are on stage and
how long in your career was that
a few years in i mean i mean now i would
look back and be like oh i was awful but
for the time i was able to go you know
i'm i i'm good enough to be on the stage
with these guys
and uh i was like why are they on the
stage so i started analyzing the people
i saw at all the clubs
and it was like sharat small like james
smith and these kind of
comics and um
they were all on best week ever i
noticed all the comics who are best week
ever were performing at all the clubs
christian finnegan
and i was like okay i need to get on a
show that is a weekly show
that will give me some leverage so now
because it's not just about funny
it's like if you're as funny as all the
other guys okay
you got to be funnier than them and have
something so i got on uh guy code
and that was my weekly now i had some
leverage now i could go to a club and be
like i'm on a tv show every week
can i get on yeah how do you how did you
get on guy code
i uh make it sound so easy uh yeah it
was it was
it was kind of there was some you know
one of the good things like knowing what
you want to do
so like i i did a new year's eve show
like
one of those countdown shows for mtv so
i got into the mtv door
they really liked me so i um
had a meeting with them i was pitching a
show
which i ended up not really wanting to
do but at least like the person saw it
was interesting
and then while pitching it uh she asked
me like what my thing was and i was just
like i just you know i got a guy's
perspective like
i'm unapologetically male and you know
this is how i feel and i'd like to be
the voice for
you know for uh for men nowadays and i
feel like they don't really have a voice
and all of a sudden guy code came down
the pipeline and she remembered that
meeting she's like i'd like to suggest a
guy
now had i never said what i truly want
to do
maybe i would have never got that
meeting right most people
i think put this white umbrella this
wide net but the net is so wide it never
catches anything
and i'm saying if you say specifically
what you want to do to people when a
project comes up to specific
they'll think about you for it if you're
like i just want to be on television
nobody's remembering the meeting where
the guy goes i just want to be on
television
and going okay i should put that they
will remember the meeting they said
listen i love monster trucks that's my
[ __ ] i'm a monster truck
aficionado if a monster truck show comes
on
thinking back i remember meeting this
guy who's into monster trucks you know
what i'm saying so know what you want
and then when something comes down the
line
people tag you for it there was one time
you were on
five shows yeah simultaneously yeah
i was a guy at mtv for a minute so you
understand the tv game and all that
maybe you could provide some insight
into
maybe first off even just how to pitch a
show what are they yeah i mean i didn't
pitch any of them
you know yeah i was just i just had a
contract with mtv and they could put me
on as many things as they wanted
and um there was a moment in in history
an mtv where i was the guy you know i
hosted everything from
a dating show to his jobs show i was
on guy code girl code jobs that don't
suck i hosted spring break i hosted
another
you know festival like i was just they
would just throw me on
the awards show in europe yeah yeah i
hosted the emas out there in europe for
like the american syndication of it
but it was um it was a cool time man i
was just busy as [ __ ] and
bouncing around they put me on
everything it was it was definitely cool
yeah we're not on the same page anymore
is that you just grew apart or an event
happened uh
i think an event sparked it but also
they it was also
some frustration on both of our parts um
you know i i i hm i also think maybe
like uh
i don't want to blame my manager but i
think my manager made some poor
decisions at the time i'm no longer with
him but i think that
led to a kind of aggravated relationship
between the two of us
like he allowed me to do a show on a
competing channel that i thought was
okay to do
but it turns out it wasn't that kind of
pissed off the mtv
folks but after we already had a little
bit of a
you know kind of tumultuous relationship
i didn't want to do any more corny shows
gotcha i had bad experiences with a
couple corny shows and i realized i'm
not really into that i want to do these
kind of fun
interesting shows and um
they also wanted to make a show kind of
based on brilliant idiots
and i felt that that was our
entity in our project and they kind of
felt like since they introduced me and
charlemagne that they
owned it not owned it but like we're
entitled to it creatively in some way
i was like nah fam that's not what it is
so that show ends up
being uncommon sense which is
charlemagne's show oh okay
and um and i was asked to be on it
you know but originally those talks
started with the possibility of us doing
some sort of
brilliant idiot show or is it a segment
on a show or how we
how we do it and i was just protective
of it i was
you know i remember they called me it
was like hey we want you and uh
charlemagne to do this like weekly show
where you guys have uh i remember
they're all on the phone it was
they asked me to come for a meeting but
it snowed so we ought to call we want
you to have this weekly show where you
guys you know talk about the pop culture
things
you and charlemagne and um
and then you maybe have a guest and then
you take questions from fans
now the formula for brilliant idiots is
we talk about pop culture
have a guess and then we do ask an idiot
that's what we were doing
so when they said that to me i was just
on the phone and they're waiting for me
to be like oh my god awesome guys thank
you so much
and i was like well isn't that brilliant
idiots and they're like well this is a
popular format
and i was like all right cool man you
know and then like we want to call it
guy code live and i go well haven't we
done the whole guy code thing already
isn't that that's already kind of
well the guide code brand is bigger than
you know brilliant idiots brand
it absolutely was but
they just didn't like my lack of
enthusiasm gotcha yeah
do you know how guy code all got started
because i had billy sorelle's on here
are you familiar with
billy sorel how do i know that guy well
there was a whole controversy where he
had
this youtube segment that then magically
appeared as this mtv2 show
called guy code so he had a show called
guy code
it wasn't called guy code but there were
like specific sketches
that were pretty much mirror image yeah
no like what there was like a whole
lawsuit and everything
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm serious
yeah he's on wild and out now and
everything so he's like
he's back he's been working with mtv too
again but like
yeah it was it was a whole ordeal he had
to sit down with like viacom and
everything
wow he sued flyacon but i guess
i guess as the talent you guys don't
hear the behind the scenes but it was
just interesting
i don't know if you knew god no no i
know the guy who made it
uh ryan ling and he's put me in a bunch
of other stuff and you know i continue
to work with ryan
um i mean i'll be honest i don't think
there's any creative genius behind the
idea of
a show that just talks about what men
should do i mean gq has been telling us
to do that for years
maxim's been telling us to do that for
years i don't think the
i don't think the idea is that novel
it just so happened that it was put into
a place where people really gravitated
to it
yeah and you've seen similar like the
comedy central
like with the the david tells stand-up
show where you were you were talking to
comedy central
you just passingly about this oh yeah
you just appeared david tell at the same
thing
you were talking about yeah yeah that's
so funny wow yeah you've done your
research
you go deep um yeah that's right i had a
meeting with comey comey central never
put me on their channel
uh and uh you have never gotten that
much love from the stand-up comedy
industry
it's very interesting um but uh
but yeah the uh but yeah i remember i
had a meeting with them and
i was like yeah it'd be really cool you
know you just showcase like what it's
like in a club
you know and i was talking to and i
remember as i mentioned i was talking to
david tell about it like yeah it'd be
cool just showcasing
you know what it's like to be in a club
in new york you know and that kind of
experience
and when we shoot at you know
underground and stuff yeah like yeah
that's interesting
never heard back from them and then i
just saw that show come on
comedy central and the worst part was
they didn't even ask me
to be in the [ __ ] show right you know
what i mean i don't know if you already
had that in a pipeline or not but it's
like
if you did have it in the pipeline you
might as well mention it in the meeting
so you don't look like you know you're
biting the [ __ ] that i'm pitching you
but this happens this happens all the
time yeah why do you think you haven't
been
as i guess like a better word embraced
in the stand-up world
it's it's a it's a weird thing i think
there's a lot of maybe judge a book by
its cover with me you know i think like
people see me
they're like i maybe don't look like a
traditional goofy
weirdo stand-up guy you know i think i
kind of look like the guy who maybe
bullied these people in high school
which is why they're a stand-up in the
first place right right right
so i think that's the assumption of me
because when people see my set
actually the initial reaction is this i
am this way
oh he's [ __ ] douchey you know [ __ ]
uh
beer pong bro frat boy you know and then
you see my set and it's like oh [ __ ] no
this is like good
thoughts this guy's kind of smart what's
going on oh this is not what i expected
and um i just feel like you need to get
past that in order
to maybe to maybe see me but i've never
been really championed by the industry
in that in that regard
i'm also like a 30 year old white dude
that's not really what the industry's
looking for right now
if i was trans i'd be on every [ __ ]
stand-up special in the world
that being said outside whatever makes
your life
harder in life makes it easier for you
and stand up
whatever makes it easy for you to stand
up makes your life
way harder in life does that make sense
yeah you know what i mean yeah it's true
so being six two with a full head of
hair
white makes life pretty great you know
stand up i gotta work extra hard
to compete with these people better grow
a beard and put on a flannel shirt
exactly yeah i gotta fit
some even that's probably played out i
gotta have something else yeah yeah i
gotta be like autistic
how can he overcome this it's like it's
like funny
is not about funny anymore it's about
like boxes you check off like
and it sounds it sounds bitter but
i don't actually mind it and it it
bothered me a lot
at first because it was like ah this is
what i love and i and i
i'm on stage with these people and i
know i'm funnier than them so that's
never been a question
but it's like man why why haven't i been
embraced in the same way or given the
same opportunities you know
like even for me to do montreal you know
the comedy festival yeah
like for most people to do new faces on
montreal they're a new face to comedy
they haven't done anything in the comedy
world
for me to do new faces i already had a
six figure deal with mtv
and i already had two of my own shows
that i was hosting coming on to air
and two tv shows that i was like a major
part of that were already on air
so you know how like you hear people
talk about like
uh marginalized minorities about what
they need to do
in order to get a shot you know like
what barack needed to actually overcome
in order to be president is way
different than george bush
or whatever like that like what i had to
do just to get new faces in montreal was
unprecedented that's impressive nobody's
been more qualified
for new faces in montreal history than
me that's got to be a fact
how many years into your career was that
i don't know i forget to be honest with
you
but um yeah but never invited back to
montreal either
very interesting there's something
there's some kind of
i don't know if it's stigma it's so
interesting it's like in order for me
the weird thing for me has always been
like give me the people not the industry
if you give me the people we're good
like i'm the guy who like
you i you gotta just test the show like
you put me on the show
and you're like all right we'll put them
on i think it's fine and then you get
the results back from when you test the
do the pilot test right
they're like oh yeah we love that guy
the people love that and then
the network embraces it so my feeling is
like just get it to the people i don't
want to hear what you got to say
network don't worry about it yeah you
guys have your opinions that's fine just
give it to the people
they'll tell you what to do have you
tried to even do like late night spots
like a coney or anything
i i started preparing it a little bit
and i was so miserable
in preparing it that i just was like i
don't one want to do this
two i don't see the return on investment
you know like it's it's it's you're
investing time
you're investing fun like now it's not
fun
to work on these sets i don't get to do
comedy how i normally do comedy or speak
how i want to speak on stage
and the return on investment is what
nothing right the credit we already have
credits it's like
i already have tv you know so like and i
already have something that brings
people to the shows
so it's like would i do it yes would i
love to do the couch where we have the
conversation
absolutely and will i eventually do it
in the future sure
but it wasn't something i felt like
would really help me now
that's what's interesting is you've done
all this television
but pretty much everybody at your show
last night
was from the podcast yeah tv doesn't do
the same thing anymore
he's lost his power yeah it's just it's
not that his loss of power but one
there's just so much tv
but two there's a difference between
being on tv and being on something you
watch
a guy was a lead in the sitcom nobody
comes out to shows because of that
so sitcom on on ifc called benders now
it's on netflix
did one season nobody's on the nobody
comes out to show us because of that
guy code was a wildly popular show
peop these kids who watch it were a
little too young to come out to the
comedy club
but when i would do colleges there were
a thousand people in the audience
it was unbelievable lines down the
[ __ ]
campus i mean it was unbelievable when
we would do these shows
so there's a difference between just
being on tv
doesn't mean people come out to your
shows you have to be on something that
people relate to and [ __ ] with
and the podcast is the extreme version
of that instead of me being on your tv
screen for a total of 45 seconds in one
episode
of guy code i'm in your ears
two hours a week you know my family
you know my brother you know my my
friends
you know the shitty things that are
happening to me you know the good things
are happening to me you know the girl
that i'm
dating you know everything about my life
i'm one of your good friends you know
more about me than you know about most
of the people
that you work with so if i come to your
city yeah you're gonna come say what's
up
you already invested all his time in my
life you're gonna not say hi when i'm
here
yeah it's a different relationship with
podcasts when i speak to people
listening to podcasts i'm not speaking
of fans
i'm speaking of people know me it's a
different relationship
what are some common mistakes you're
seeing comedians make because everybody
wants to generate a fan base
and everybody has their own idea of what
works but you seem to have a really
interesting
and smart view on kind of how this game
works so really any insight you have
would be greatly appreciated i don't
know man i've always searched for
leverage
and i grew up in a small family business
my parents they owned a business they
owned a dance studio
but i saw the leverage that they had you
know they owned the studio so they
my dad could take off work if he needed
to take me to a basketball game or some
[ __ ] you know
um my mom you know they always look for
leverage in things
you know my mom was immigrant she's from
scotland stop going to school like 15
ends up buying property in new york you
know because of her success and like
buys a beach house but
even with the beach house and that kind
of [ __ ] her mentality was well we could
just rent this out if we need to pay for
something
we could just rent the home here in new
york out if we need to do so like
how do you you know the second they
bought the home in new york they created
an apartment
to within it to rent it out it was
constantly
safety and security so with me i'm
thinking out of my career all the time
okay if this [ __ ] with mtv stops what do
i got
oh i got this podcast popular okay
that's going to sustain me financially
okay good now i gotta branch [ __ ] off on
the podcast
how do i create leverage in the world oh
can i get people to a show yeah
can i get more people to a show than
than some of these people who are on tv
yeah maybe the clubs won't recognize
that at first but once i come there
boom so how do you have leverage in this
business
these guys on social media who frankly
aren't even close to as funny as many of
my favorite comedians have all the
leverage they're making way more money
than people on tv now
because they have leverage they could
say hey i got eight million fans
and i can tell eight million people to
watch this show
how much is that worth to you nbc how
much does that work to you netflix
it's worth real money if you're a really
funny comedian
but you only got a thousand followers on
instagram
you can only tell a thousand people come
to your show now nbc's got to do all the
work
and getting people come to the show if
i'm nbc
and this instagram comedian who
auditions
just as well as this 1 000 follower
comedian
did it's a no-brainer who i'm gonna pick
think about how much better you you are
gonna have to be for that role
if you have no leverage in order to be
chosen you gotta be
it's worth not telling eight million
people
for free
funny so is that your your whole game
was
you want to get undeniably funny first
that's first not everything comes from
that
and you're always growing and you were
i loved your hustle with that because
you would actually transcribe
like dave chappelle's specials you were
looking at the math
yeah of comedy or do you still take that
same approach in analyzing your sets now
it's more like the matrix now it's more
like neo you know like neil when he sees
the green [ __ ]
like that's how it is when you watch
comedy now you're just like oh i see
what he did there okay
back in the day you didn't know how to
see the matrix right so you have to
write it down and really [ __ ]
translate what is he doing here
how how is his premise and how does okay
like i was trying to understand the
language of comedy so now i understand a
language
so it's it's less like i don't even like
watching famous guys because i want them
to influence me but
if i do watch it it will just be like
okay this is really
it's more to inspire me to push it
further
you know like dave chappelle's recent
special i love the structure of it
so now i'm thinking about with specials
it's like it's got to be more than just
an hour of jokes there's got to be some
arc
yeah you know i mean it's gotta be
something pulling this whole thing
together what is it
so now that's how i think about a
special because of him and you actually
funded your own special right yeah i
shot my own yeah and we've been
struggling to sell it man it's perfect
example
like you would think that that would be
a no-brainer you know i shot a sitcom
[ __ ] comes on netflix people see you
know you go see me live
that's undeniable in terms of you know
funny
um i've been on tv i have a podcast
quarter million subscribe you know
people listen like
you would think that with these things
it's a no-brainer
compared to the people that are getting
opportunities for specials
the only thing i could chalk it up to is
i mean honestly i just i the oh i can't
i don't even understand it besides the
fact that like maybe
30 year old white guys aren't cool right
now
to give special to that's the only thing
i could chalk it up to you think it's
the structure because isn't yours like
in 15 minute chunks which makes even
better
it's unique like that's what you that's
even better like
so the way i did the special was i did
five different comedy clubs in new york
and i taped the
the hour over those five clubs and then
i tape the cab rides in between
so it gives you an idea of what the
night was like this is a night in new
york
for people who are comedy fans there's
folklore
to be a new york comedian and so you
could do 20 spots a night you could do
whatever so like
this is a real inside look at what it is
to be a new york comic
and i gave you the hour special as well
and um
i did this purposely because i knew if i
just did a regular special
it wouldn't it wouldn't be enough i knew
how
big i had to be as a as a as like a
celebrity in order to sell
special right so
and i knew i didn't have that just on
name
right because i don't have any other
like box to check off like if i you know
i'm saying if i was like part penguin
and i was doing a comedy then it would
be like he's a penguin guy
you know you know you've got to check
out this penguin person's comedy special
or whatever right
so i knew that so i'm like what i'll do
is i'll make something artistic as well
i'll increase the equity of this special
increase the value
right that's how i'm thinking about it
and um and we've been talking to people
you know
we've been back and forth with certain
people and there's there's interest in
certain places and just a certain place
we're like no sorry your name's not big
enough this that the other
oh what oh i was depressed man i was
like is what's wrong am i not getting
this like
it's very difficult to go on a road
crush
go in the city crush with the same
material and be like no i know this is a
good material
i feel proud of it and then be rejected
over and over again for
the special right because you're like
was it not good
what's going on you got to like re-watch
it and be like no it's good right
yeah yeah i believe in this kind of
stuff you know it was a very difficult
time for me man you were actually like
you were depressed like you actually
i was just down on it you know down on
comedy it was down on you know i was
just down on myself i thought it would
sell on a [ __ ] day
like that we were getting no's from
places i didn't even want to sell it to
like i was like yeah you can show it to
showtime but i'm not going to give it to
you know what i mean like like i sell it
to them you know what man we're going
netflix or hbo that's it
you know like and then when they were
saying no he's like what do you mean no
what is it
i didn't get the chance to say no first
you know so
it was just a reality check so what do
you what do you
what do you think's missing or like what
are you trying to do to
make sure it happens like you said you
set goals and
you make sure you be specific about what
you want to happen so you want this to
be released what do you
well i mean i basically decide this and
i my feel
my feeling with this which i was which
what i thought was a no-brainer is i
hear i have this podcast
that has a quarter million people
listening per episode
this is my leverage this is what i can
offer a network i can bring these people
to you to watch this show i know that
you're not choosing people for your
specials based on just comedic merit
right because i see the specials you
know what i mean
is not to [ __ ] on people but you know it
is what it is there's you know comedy's
not entirely subjective we know that
there's funny specials we know there's
not funny specials
yeah just how the reality is um i'm not
saying i'm dave chappelle
dave spells you are gonna be the
greatest comedian ever i'm not saying
i'm patrice o'neill's
the greatest greatest comedian there but
there are people who have specialists
out that i know that i'm
funnier than and this is a better
special than um
so
i i i felt like my leverage would be
okay you're giving this person a special
but he can't bring you numbers and eyes
i can offer something funnier and
numbers and i like this is a business
transaction let's treat this like
business
i have people who want to see the
special plus you have your people who
like comedy
let's bring these two worlds together
ta-da
no-brainer some people
it's a brainer i guess for everyone so
far i guess
it is very it was very difficult very
difficult so what i basically said was
look if we don't get it off if we don't
get it sold soon what i'm gonna do is
release it myself
and i'll prove the product myself i
think that's what you have to do
yeah that's what i tell everybody do
everybody complains about the industry
as being so racist this that the other
just make your own movie
if it's successful everybody will want
to make a movie with you
and that is the good thing about having
the power and having numbers is that you
can
do it your way now and another guy of
course
your right hand man charlemagne has done
it his way as well
i mean this guy is another rising stock
what have you learned unbelievable from
working
side by side with this guy just
unbelievable talent he's probably the
most talented person i've ever worked
with
he's unbelievable relentless work ethic
and just an unbelievable talent
and um he's made me much better what i
do that's for sure
you know uh just made me really buckle
down and like
you know i'm i'm confident i speak well
enough and [ __ ] well enough where i
can get people to believe [ __ ] even if i
don't have anything to back it up
and he does that even better than i do
so what he forced me to do was
find statistics and research to back up
my claims
because if we just get into a [ __ ]
combo he's gonna win
he's an unbelievable bullshitter
unbelievable
nobody's better right at just the art of
like
communicating a point he just knows how
to do it
and uh so what it forced me to do is get
my point and then
get things that are irrefutable to back
it up and it made me a much better
communicator i'm very grateful
for him for for for forcing me to do
that he's not like something he told me
to do
but it's something that working with
somebody who's that good made me do
and help you with the business side as
well absolutely his business acumen's
great i mean he's just his strategy his
good strategy
but it was just one of those things
where it's like and the podcast made me
realize this is like if you build it and
it works people will [ __ ] with you
you know and that's why i say to
everybody it's like and i take my own
advice like with this special i'll put
out myself
prove that people [ __ ] with it prove
that it's hot make it hot
with my fans and supporters from the
podcast and other things
and then all of a sudden the industry
would be like oh we noticed
that your special's really good uh we
would love to work with you on another
special
when a week ago it was now we're good
yeah
that's how this business works they want
to be second that's what everybody keeps
complaining
they go oh my god it's so racist is that
no they just don't want to be the first
one
you know empire comes out right you
always hear this [ __ ] about they're like
oh they're not giving
black people opportunities in hollywood
empire comes out right
success immediately after empire comes
out they release power on stars
vh1 has this is the beat or something
like that or the beats or the whatever
netflix releases another hip-hop bass
show called
oh yeah by buzz lerman uh fx releases
atlanta
literally every channel releases their
version
of a hip-hop show hip-hop music kind of
show
that is what hollywood is once you prove
that it works everybody else
wants a piece of it so it's
not that hollywood is explicitly racist
and mean meaning they're like like we
got to keep asians out of hollywood we
got to keep whatever out of hollywood we
got to keep black we got to hunt that's
not about what it's about
it's one they're clueless they've
they're just so detached from anything
that isn't their exact world
and two they're just not willing to risk
the money once you prove it makes money
do whatever the [ __ ] you want the guy
who may get out jordan peel or whatever
he can make whatever he wants now mm-hmm
he can make whatever he wants
it's a blank check for whatever his next
movie is because he proved the product
so if no one's giving me an opportunity
i'm taking my own advice
i'm gonna sell the [ __ ] product i'm
gonna get all my friends to
you know support it hopefully and tell
people about it you know go on podcasts
like this promote it
do grassroots get people to talk about
it and hopefully
get some buzz and the people themselves
show that hey there's interest in what i
do
and then we have all these conv
conversations with the
the you know the uh the networks
and then i get to remind them that they
said no the first time and then i give
you the leverage though
i don't need you yeah you know what i'm
saying my dick's getting sucked
why should i pull my dick out of this
girl's mouth so you could suck it
that's the conv that's where we're going
so now you got to prove
my dick's getting sucked and it's lovely
right so now you're coming over
and you're like i want to suck your dick
and it's like all right well what are
you going to do different
you know what i mean because i'm going
to come with this so what are you gonna
do dip
you know what i mean i wanted you to
suck my dick that's why i came to you
you know what i mean i came to you first
so you could suck my dick and you said
no
so now you're gonna need some extra [ __ ]
dude what a great analogy that was
that's what this business is man
you can't be upset don't be bitter just
be better
boom oh we better be better man that's
really what it comes down to
don't be bitter be better that's what it
is that's why everybody gets all upset
about like there's a lack of opportunity
like
i even hear people saying this [ __ ] like
oh they aren't giving you know
white guys roles anymore this that the
other like i hear people in the street
people saying [ __ ] and it's like good
good this is what are you upset about
first of all it's good that we have
diversity
in hollywood second it's just gonna make
you better it's gonna make you write
your own project
it's gonna make you write the role that
you actually want instead of just lazily
going to any [ __ ] audition
are you riding any uh more pilots or
anything right now
i'm kind of like off and on working on
this show
but um you sound super enthused about it
no i'm really enthused to work with
work with because we were i was working
on with whitney cummings and i think
she's just so [ __ ] brilliant so
talented and i really like working with
her on it
but uh i'm not passionate enough about
it to work
on it on my own as of now
i'm passionate to work with her on it
and i think we could create something
really funny and really special
seems like you're good at surrounding
yourself with the right people
i'm picky yeah you know i mean like i
have a very small circle
you know i'm not really like one of
these and that's probably why i don't
get certain opportunities the other
comics get
like i don't get invites these festivals
and that kind of [ __ ] like that because
i don't really
hang out with comics that much i have my
close
comic friends and um
and yeah and i'm and i'm yeah it's just
i like the people i like
so if i like you i'll [ __ ] with you and
i want to be around you but it's very
difficult for me to
be around you if i don't think you're
funny
you know what i'm saying because like
i'm going to want to help you but if i
don't think you're funny it's hard for
me to help you
yeah but if i think you're funny i'm
going to force you into [ __ ] and i
forced
my buddy akash into getting jobs
when they said no to him like i just
told him to keep coming
and eventually they just buckled down
and just started paying him
you know like yeah but like if i believe
in you that's that will happen so i
believe you know
before charlemagne was charlemagne he
was just this other guy on
the show with me on guy code and then he
had a morning show the breakfast club
that i never listened to because i
listened to hot 97 my whole life growing
up
if you're in new york 105 1 was like
this other [ __ ] hot 97 is what we listen
to
now high 97 is trash now it's all the
breakfast club
but you know for real new yorkers we
never listened to 1051.
so it was just somebody who i saw on the
show and i gravitated to because i
thought he was truly talented
you know and that's why i want to work
with them so i feel the same way with
little duval
there are plenty of people that were on
that show that
i just don't work with regularly and
they they're really nice guys and i
think that they are
they have great talent in certain areas
but it just wasn't
i didn't want to i didn't want to create
with them i didn't have that urge
what is your like your writing regimen
are you daily do you have a daily
discipline like
because you're doing a lot i need to get
more discipline yeah i'm more
disciplined with preparing for the
podcast
okay but in terms of writing i need to
get more discipline i need to put that
in the schedule and just take some time
just like talk out ideas i need to do
that
you're more are you more vocal i like
interviewed mark norman on here and he
said his whole writing process is he
just walks around the room for an hour
talking through bits are you more vocal
you pin to paper more
i can do that i'm definitely not pen to
paper i've never penned paper
um i like conversation that's how i
write
like if i have a talk with somebody
mm-hmm and we're talking about an idea
that's where it will come out like i'll
be like okay it's what's going on or
something that's funny there's something
there that's good
you know that will be that's the i don't
it's very hard for me to just be like oh
here's a joke
one of my favorite jokes of yours is the
the mexicans stealing our jobs oh yeah
yeah the joke
is absolutely brilliant and so well put
together thank you
i should put that [ __ ] up before there's
no more mexicans here dude
and talking about that joke for just a
second sure did it start with you
hearing maybe in conversation people
saying mexicans are stealing our jobs
and then you just
take it to this whole level how did you
kind of develop that joke i've always
had like a
an affinity um for mexicans and mexican
culture
you know i lived in spain and i came
back to california and i worked in
restaurants
with these guys who literally would work
uh 18 hours a day
um seven days a week six seven days a
week
uh i have families here send money back
to their families there they tell me
these amazing stories of how they got
into america and like
just hearing about what they're
able to do just to support their
families back home
i just had this real i don't know i was
just i just thought they were just such
a special people man
like really special people yeah and i
would hear people say nah they're still
in the jobs that kind of stuff like that
it just didn't sit right to me so it was
my way of kind of like defending
defending these people who i didn't
think were stealing jobs i thought they
were
doing the american thing that we've done
for years here which is a new immigrant
class comes and
they do the jobs nobody else wants to do
and that's how it started
but then to actually make it funny like
we're like oh give me your dishes
and all that yeah yeah yeah it's just uh
i don't know why i thought that i don't
even know i forget how i
how this came about man i think i wonder
if it started
you have a lot of good examples in there
i guess you had to go through a lot of
that joke has evolved it's been a long
time it's a
there's been a long i mean that's but
joke's been
around a while that was like one of the
first one of my first jokes that did
really well uh okay you know yeah
yeah that was one of the first ones that
did very you know you have these jokes
i'm sure you recognize it as a stand-up
where you're just like
all right this is this one works like i
can remember the first joke that worked
consistently and then the first joke
that really kind of killed
and uh yeah
it just clicks some just come together
yeah they just come together you know
you get these fights so that was one of
them i'm trying to think exactly what
the
what they oh man i don't know exactly
where it came about that's a bummer that
i can't remember that
but yeah it's evolved and then there's
this whole other thing i don't know if i
did the whole thing that do the apple
juice
or the apple and if we can sell oranges
we can sell apple yeah yeah
just making that connection i mean do
you just write on stage
more like you just talk about stealing
our jobs and that just kind of came
together piece by piece over time
basically okay i just thought it was
kind of like that's how things happen to
me like the idea of like
like i'll think about something i'll be
honest the one thing that annoys me
about that joke is it's likeable
like the joe the joke is pretty likable
like i think most people have
you know a a little bit of compassion
for mexican immigrants
right i don't i tend to gravitate
towards humor that you have no
compassion for
definitely and then you defend it and
then i defend it right so so this is
this is a joke that like i'm kind of
like a good guy on
which is the one thing i don't like
about that being said it's like
something
i do believe you know what i mean i like
being a bad guy in every joke that's so
fun
but that's what it comes to it's like
you hear somebody say something they're
stealing the jobs or even like with the
grab the [ __ ] thing
and like i'll just ruminate on that i'm
like grabbing a [ __ ] is it wrong to
grab the [ __ ] like how do you grab a
[ __ ] like how do you
well how do you have i ever grabbed a
[ __ ] yeah i've grabbed it matter of
fact i've always grabbed poison i never
asked for permission to grab [ __ ] i
just grabbed [ __ ] right
so like that's where it goes right yeah
you know instead of just like
accepting conventional wisdom which is
all these people think it's wrong okay i
think it's wrong
yeah it's impressive that you you did
that joke and you're like but you've
never met a billionaire
you had women clapping yeah yeah that's
that i mean that's just amazing to just
flip people like that it's
it was really fun to watch i'm glad you
liked it yeah man
it was it was great to see you work live
and it was great for you to share this
time with me man my brother
i really appreciate your generosity for
sure uh before we get out of here
is there anything else you want the
world to know oh man they could check
out all the things i'm doing just on
on uh my podcast the brilliant idiots
and uh also um just twitter and
instagram i usually you know keep posted
that's uh andrew schultz schulz
mm-hmm so yeah but um yeah man thanks
for having me bro appreciate it and
check him out on sneaky pete too you
might have
a little cameo yeah that was a cool
couple episodes man
but uh yeah andrew schultz thanks for
being on hot breath man my brother thank
you very much
you